the white-rumped vulture hasn't gotten
much respect in Bangladesh it's hunched
slate-gray wings bald head and taste for
carrion have marked it as a symbol of
doom but the Raptors bad image isn't
stopping conservationists from trying to
save it from extinction South Asian
governments and conservationists are
spending millions of dollars to pull
this vulture and two other species back
from the brink the plunge of South
Asia's vulture population began in the
1990s the epidemic stretched across the
subcontinent hitting three vulture
species the white-rumped vulture has
declined by 99% in India the population
went from 10 million to around 6,000 the
other two species have followed similar
trajectories in 2004 scientists and
pakistan found the culprit by examining
the carcasses of cattle some species of
vulture can't metabolize diclofenac a
painkiller that became widely used in
the 1990s to treat cattle when the birds
feed on tainted carcasses uric acid
crystallizes in their kidneys kidney
failure and death soon follow
vultures species that are able to
metabolize the drug haven't suffered
population collapsed the disappearance
of these vultures translates into the
loss of one of nature's tiniest ways to
dispose of a dead body a crew of
vultures can strip a dead cow to its
bones in less than an hour moving a
source of stench and potential disease
governments in the region have responded
by banning the veterinary version of
diclofenac in most places however
veterinarians can still use diclofenac
most common alternatives which are also
toxic to vultures the proliferation of
problem drugs and the reluctance of
governments to ban all of them puts a
premium on finding more benign
medications
a variety of veterinary painkillers are
currently being studied for their
effects on vultures but this process is
time consuming and many drugs remain on
the market that haven't been tested on
vultures meanwhile bird numbers are so
low that even a small crack in the bands
could prove catastrophic a 2004 study
estimated that diclofenac contamination
of as few as one in 760 cow carcasses
could drive down vulture numbers to
prevent further declines
conservationists and collaboration with
governments are trying to create
vultures safe zones in Bangladesh in
2014 the government designated two
vultures zones a circle with a 100
kilometer radius centered on a spot
where imperiled vultures gathered inside
these safe zones conservationists
quartered veterinarians with educational
material warning of the perils of some
drugs and free stockpiles of meloxicam a
painkiller that's safe for vultures some
evidence suggests this strategy is
having an impact surveys found nearly
all pharmacies in Bangladesh stopped
selling diclofenac by the end of 2015
down from 25% in 2014 in November 2017
researchers in Nepal released 17
white-rumped vultures tagged with
satellite tracking systems the first to
be tracked this way if these birds along
with others released in the coming year
survived until April 2020 without a
drug-related fatality the region will be
declared an official vulture safe zone